this is the first of several videos on
Heidegger as the origin of the work of
art a speech and a say that he gave
several times expanding on it at
different points in his career it's a
very important work both for
understanding Heidegger in general I
think and also for understanding
Heidegger is orientation towards
existentialism and so I'm going to spend
a lot of time going over it I think that
it can't be done in simply one video
lecture one hour of footage and I have
three preliminary things that I'd like
to say before actually going into the
the work itself and these are so to
speak outside of the frame you might say
so the first thing is you're going to
notice me moving a little bit
differently in this video than I have in
my other videos in part that's because
if you're a regular viewer of mine and
if you're not a regular viewer I invite
you to become one you know that I tour
two ligaments in my left knee this
summer and that at this point they have
not yet been surgically replaced a lot
of physical therapy to do before that
occurs and what better way to they don't
bring home our mortality to us if we
want to think in HIDA gary and thieves
are thrown this so I have a brace and I
move back and forth but you know there's
a little bit less mobility so if you're
wondering what's going on because you
can't see it off camera that's the story
the second thing is I would like to
actually dedicate this video and the
next I think two videos to somebody who
is studying Heidegger right now somebody
I'm very happy to know is delving into
Heidegger and specifically into this
work and that is my wife Andy Chaka who
currently is at the time that I'm
shooting this in sauce face with Sir
Linda at European graduate school and
European graduate school is really about
cutting edge continental philosophy they
bring in some some big names
and they also do a lot of foundational
work and one of the thinkers who is
particularly important for them is
Heidegger and I think this is one of the
essays that is particularly well
discussed by them and so I'm creating
this not only for for you my viewers but
also in part for my wife to help her
make her way through this labyrinth of
high daguerreian ideas the third thing
is I'm pretty sure that this is going to
require at least three video lectures
perhaps more you saw in the Nietzsche
lecture on the genealogy that I thought
it would just be three and it took for
Kierkegaard philosophical fragments I
thought would take three and it took
seven so this work may in fact demand
quite a bit more because there's a lot
of things densely packed into this so
those are my three preliminary
observations there is something else
that I'd like to say before we actually
start looking at the text and that is we
want to think a little bit about why
this particular work is so important and
so let's do a little bit of big-picture
broad theme kind of meanderings first so
is this really an essay that is just
about artwork is this an essay in
aesthetics let's say well no because as
it turns out for Heidegger as we're
going to see art is deeply
interconnected at its root in its
essence with two other really key well
several other key things what is being
not just being with it with a small bead
but with a capital B which is one of the
grand themes of Heidegger's metaphysical
works it's also intimately connected
with truth and this is where Heidegger
is doing something quite interesting
he's not the only person to connect you
know artwork with truth
and beauty with truth but he is really
bringing it home and he has his own
particular conception of truth that he
thinks is in some ways what he calls
more primordial than a lot of the other
notions of truth and if you want to know
more about Heidegger on truth I would
invite you to watch the video that I
have on the essence of truth another one
of Heidegger is important works another
thing that I think is particularly
important and often gets overlooked
because people focus on the themes early
on is that artwork for Heidegger is not
only connected with metaphysical schemes
it's also something that is an
expression of our historical being our
our development in time not only as
individuals but also in terms of
cultures and epics so all of that is
stuff that's worth keeping in mind is
kind of lampposts or you know far-off
lighthouses giving you an idea of where
we're going so let's start though at the
very beginning at least the beginning of
the tax returns which turns out to be an
an exposition or examination of what
really ought to be the beginning point
so Heidegger starts out well enough by
saying origin here means that from which
and by which something is what it is and
as it is so origin he's understanding in
a genetic sense as what makes the thing
what it is the kind of thing that it is
the type of being that it is and as it
is how that being is so how it gives
itself in phenomenological language so
we're beginning with origin and we're
already starting to move into
discussions of essence because what is
an essence traditionally the essence is
of a thing is what the thing is it tells
you what that that thing actually in its
heart in its kernel in what makes it
that kind of thing what it is so he says
what something is we call it its essence
the origin of something is
the source of its essence so origin here
has a position that is a little bit more
primordial than just essence we want to
know not just what is the thing how did
that thing come to be that thing so he
says the question concerning the origin
of the work of art asks about its
essential source where does art actually
come from on the usual view you notice
I've got your artist and artwork on the
usual view we look at as well you want
to know the origin of the work of art
somebody actually made it some artists
put together that artwork so if you want
to know why the artwork is that way well
you know if you go to a gallery what's
one of the things that you'll you'll see
and I often find these ranging from the
hilarious to the confusing to the
infuriating artist statements and an
artist statement tells you this is what
I was trying to do in the artwork or
here's why I did things this way here's
why the things that you are seeing
experiencing before you are the way that
they are the reason why I don't like
them too much is because artists often
mix in a lot of terribly thought-out
philosophy into it and then when you ask
them about a day they don't really know
what they're talking about not to say
that all artists are in that case so now
does this solve the question he says but
by what and whence is the artist what he
is this is something well we're thinking
about
can anybody set themselves up as an
artist so long as they're producing
artwork does that make you an artist
think of it let's say we get away from
painting or you know things like that
and we take music if I get out of
recorder and I know how to play the
recorder it's not very well and I start
to tooling along does that make me an
artist if I come up with some sort of
song randomly by playing notes that
I just don't know what my fingers flop
around on it does that actually make an
artwork and make me an artist I would
say no and I think most of you would say
no as well but we live in a time in
which many people at least once they're
set up as an artist can do whatever they
like and call it Earth
so there has to be something there has
to be some mutual condition the artwork
itself tells us if the person is an
artist doesn't it we evaluate somebody's
quality as an artist based on maybe
certain standards inherent in the art so
we can say that so-and-so is a greater
painter than somebody else somebody is a
greater musician or composer or you know
choreographic or ballet dancer than
somebody else somebody is a greater
sculptor somebody is a greater poet
somebody is a greater writer we must
have some sort of standards that we
judge on the basis of the artwork itself
so he says the artist is the origin of
the work the work is the origin of the
artist there's a circular relation here
neither is without the other
nevertheless neither is the sole support
of the other so we need a third term we
need something else to bring into the
picture in themselves and in their
interrelations artist and work are each
of them by virtue of a third thing which
is prior to both and that tells us we're
dealing with something that could be the
origin and that is art itself right
that gives both artist and work of
Arthur names art as necessarily as the
artist is the origin of the work in a
different way than the work is the
origin of an artist so it's equally
certainty says that in a different way
art is the origin of both artist and
work so art is actually encompassing all
of us and giving us the artists and
giving us the artwork can art be an
origin at all he says where and how does
art occur well we can ask the same
question what is our itself says this is
nothing more than a word to which
nothing actual any longer corresponds
you know Heidegger is writing at a time
when our notion of art has somewhat
broken down we have historical art but
what's going on in in actual production
so it may pass for a collective idea
under which we find a place for that
which alone is actual and art works and
artists and this is a this is a classic
problem now it's become a classic
problem for us in aesthetics what
actually constitutes art what actually
constitutes even an art like painting or
music or sculpture what is this this art
that we want to point out so he says
even if the word art were taken to
signify more than a collective notion
what is meant by the word could exist
only on the basis of the actuality of
works an artist or is the converse the
case it works an artist exists only
because art exists is their origin so he
says whatever the decision may be
whichever direction we go with this the
question of the origin of work of art
becomes a question of the essence of our
what makes art art what is that which
constitutes it as art and that over
there as not art how do we draw these
lines so he says well we have to
actually in this case
look at the relationship between the
artwork and art why because art unfolds
in the artwork the artist is important
but the artwork is really the thing that
we're looking at so he says what art is
should be inferable from the work what
the work of art is we can come to know
only from the essence of art so here we
actually instead of having just this we
have a circle we know what the artwork
is through art and we know what art is
through the artwork now here's where we
make an interesting leap here's where we
bring in what is later going to be
called the hermeneutic circle Heidegger
says ordinary understanding and logic
would tell us well if we have a circular
sort of structure we have to avoid that
why because we're not actually we're
trying to define things we're trying to
understand things and if we can't
understand what this is and we ask a
question about it doesn't help us to
refers to something else which then
requires us to refer back to the
original thing does this end up being a
vicious circle however heidegger's
answer is no why well when it comes to
things that are of central importance
things that are essential to our our way
of being in the world we have to
actually proceed through the circle why
because we can't find a completely
distinct foundation upon which we would
build everything else up the way that a
lot of philosophers have dreamed up
instead we learn something about the
artwork and then we know a little bit
more about art and that enables us to
know a little bit more about the artwork
which enables us to know a little bit
more about art and we are we are making
some progress in the process but it is
ciclo to process the progress that is it
is going in a cycle and it is spiraling
towards the heart of the matter
so he says we're compelled to follow the
circle this is neither a makeshift nor a
defect to enter up this path is the
strength of thought to continue on it is
the feast of thought assuming and this
is a big assumption that thought is a
craft that thought itself now notice the
movement that is making here that
thinking itself is something like art
that it's not a purely mechanical
process that can be reduced to
algorithms that could be encapsulated in
text books nor is it something that we
can provide perfect guidelines for
thinking itself is an activity that we
engage in that by the virtue of the kind
of beings that we are rational beings
and we can get better at it and we can
get better in it that's what it means
for it to be a craft so he says so in
order to understand the essence of the
art that actually prevails in the work
let's look at the work itself let's
focus on that and that's where the
greatest amount of effort is going to
come in this this entire essay so he
says works of art are familiar to
everyone just go to a gallery go to a
museum you see you know you walk through
wings here's the 19th century stuff
here's the you know the expressionist
painters over here here's some sculpture
so he says if we consider the works and
they're untouched actuality and do not
deceive ourselves the result is that the
works are naturally present as things
the picture hangs on the wall like a
rifle or a hat as a matter of fact for
many people with the artwork that they
they get it's a pure commodity product
and they want it to convey a certain
thing you might think about the artwork
in hotel rooms for example or in certain
galleries where they buy it
mass-produced and it looks nice but it's
just there to sort of fill in a gap so
the painting travels from one exhibition
to another works of artists ship like
coal from the Ruhr and logs from the
Black Forest so works of art actually
have what he calls a thing we care
and this is going to be a very important
term thinly English works of art exist
as things in the world what would they
be without it he says perhaps this
rather crude an external view of the
work is objectionable to us and you know
this makes sense this is why we call
some people Philistines we say they have
no real sense for what the artwork is
you know they look at it and all they
see is is some cheap paint splattered on
the canvas and they say a monkey could
do that or I could do that better so
there is the thing way the basis of the
art and then we say if somebody actually
has an appreciation for art what he
calls the much-vaunted aesthetic
experience can which cannot get around
the thing the aspect we're trying to
give that something else so what is this
higher area where distinctively artistic
qualities come into play so he says when
we're looking at art we think that it's
superfluous and confusing to inquire
into this thinly feature of it since the
artwork is something else over and above
the thing the elements this something in
the work constitutes it's our artistic
nature what is this
so the artwork is something that is made
it is something that is thinly but it
says something other than what the
mirror thing itself is and he uses some
Greek terms here he says all oh I'll go
down a which means it speaks in a
different way where it speaks of
something else and this is the word that
we or the bunch of words that we
actually get allegory from allegory is
strictly speaking when you have a story
and the story is actually telling
another story but works of art can be
allegorical as well and if you think
about what they're doing in the first
place
think about a painting the painting
itself is a bunch of splotches of
pigment on canvas we can do it on wood
or you know plaster all sorts of other
things as well let's just focus on on a
canvas so what's going on there the
canvas is actually telling us something
else it's indicating to us something
different even in non figurative works
there's a artistic level which is not
merely pigment and that's where a lot of
aesthetics has traditionally focused it
brings together another Greek word
symbolic to literally throw together or
to bring together the work is a symbol
so he says allegory and symbol provide
the conceptual frame within whose
channel the vision the artwork has long
been characterized so this is where most
aesthetics has been looking what is the
intentionality of the artist what is
what is the artist trying to picture for
us to bring before our eyes to use
Aristotle's phrase of that rhetoric he
says this one element in a work that
manifests another this one element that
joins with another is the thing we
feature in the artwork it seems almost
as though the thing the element in the
artwork is like the substructure upon
which the other proper element is built
and is it not this thing we feature the
work that the artist properly makes by
his handicraft so the artist the artists
is doing both of these right forming the
thing we feature sculptor sculpts in
stone or you know bronze or pick
whatever you like the great chef works
in a variety of mediums but the biggest
of them of course is food and drink and
then there's the higher artistic thing
and this is also coming from the artists
suite we often think as well so he says
our aim is to arrive at the immediate
and full actuality of the work of art we
cannot just focus on this we need to
also focus on this Thinley aspect of the
work of art so he says we must bring to
view the thing the elements of the work
to this end it is necessary that we
should know with sufficient clarity what
a thing is so in order to understand the
artwork as a whole and not just you know
stick with this higher part we need to
do some metaphysics we need to think
about what is a thing what do we mean by
this and Heidegger is going to look at
several different conceptions of that
now if we want to understand the thing
we character the thing we feature the
the substructure as Heidegger is called
so far of the work of art which will
allow us to understand better the other
parts the higher things that traditional
aesthetics have assigned to the work of
art we need to engage in some
metaphysics we need to ask the
fundamental question what is the thing
what is thing leanness so you know
Heidegger says in order to make sense of
this let's think of some some examples
let's let's play through the way in
which we normally talk about things
right and thing is one of those words
that not only in German and in French
and in you know other languages like
Latin gets used all the time it's
referenced not only by the word thing or
a fare or stuff like that stuff but also
just by the way in which we use our pro
no Meah
structures are indefinite pronouns it
and all those sorts of things notice I
said things in French we have you know
shows fair in German we have you know
ding zonka in Latin he is going to talk
about race ends and we have all sorts of
ways of expressing this kind of
indeterminate category that seems to
encompass so many different things so he
says well what do we mean by thing so he
says well the stone in the road is the
thing the clod in the field the jug is a
thing as is the well beside the road and
then we start to ask questions like well
what about the milk in the jug and the
water in the well well those are things
too and the cloud in the sky that this
will the field to leave in the autumn
breeze the hawk over the wood those can
all be called things it says all these
must indeed be things that the name is
applied even to that which does not like
those enumerated show itself that which
does not appear according to Conte the
whole of the world for example and even
God Himself is a thing of this sort for
example a thing that does not itself
appear a thing in itself and the
language of philosophy both things in
themselves and things that appear all
all beings that are in any way are
called things so this is broad general
category he says now this is kind of an
interesting thing that he says airplanes
and radio sets are nowadays among the
things closest to us that means the
things that are part of our everyday
experience and we might say our laptops
clothing carpets chalkboards you know
especially for me as a professor
I'm constantly finding bits of chalk in
my pockets because I just put them there
they're closest to us but when we have
in mind the last things we think of
something else very different death and
judgment these are the last things
that's something more like the Latin
race meaning with the sort of state of
affairs on the whole the word thing here
he says designates whatever is not
simply nothing so anything can be a
thing in this sense the work of art is
also a thing insofar as it is a kind of
being but this concept is not helpful
for us why not it's too broad everything
is a thing then so what is the kind of
thing that is a work of art so he says
you know if we get down to a two it's a
little weird to call some things things
we resist calling God a thing we also
hesitate to consider the peasant in the
field the stoker at the boiler the
teacher the school is things because we
call them persons right and I said well
a person is a special kind of thing but
notice when we're defining now is person
place or thing and we even see places
something a bit different than a thing
to don't we so he says a man is not a
thing it's true that we speak of a young
girl who's faced with a task too
difficult for her as being a young thing
but why because there's something
distinctively human the capacity for you
know dealing with the situation that's
missing there he says which you know
won't be missing for for long we
hesitate even called a deer in the
forest clearing the beetle in the grass
the blade of grass of thing we would
sooner think of a hammer as a thing or a
piece of truck is a thing even these are
not mere things only a stone a clod of
Earth a piece of wood are for us such
mere things so he's now switching it
from what is the thing to what is a mere
thing lifeless beings of nature
natural things and then objects of use
which is going to alternately call
utensils tools equipment in this essay
it's most often utensils and equipment
that he's talking about but you know
they're what we would call tools so he
says we see ourselves brought back from
the widest domain which in with within
which everything is a thing race and the
being to the narrow precinct of mere
things mere means here first a pure
thing which is simply a thing and
nothing more a clod of dirt is that's
just a thing piece of chalk is that just
a thing well it has a use so I suppose
it's a tool all right then a says then
at the same time it means that which is
only a thing in almost jordiz sense its
mere things excluding if utensils that
kind of things in the proper sense what
is the thing Lee character of these
things then what is that consistent so
he says this is where metaphysics not
only comes in we've already been doing a
bit of metaphysics in the process the
metaphysics in the sense of the history
of metaphysics is now going to come in
because there are three sort of standard
interpretations that have been prevalent
through the history of Western
metaphysics ever since the time of the
Greeks because the Greeks Heidegger says
this may be debatable but we're going to
stick with it here the Greeks are the
ones who first start thinking about the
quality of thing leanness as such
general being what is it to be a being
so he says no sooner was the question
raised as to what beings are in general
then things and their thing has thrust
themselves forward into prominence again
and again as the standard types of
beings so being and thing are not the
same thing they're not the same they're
not equivalent but in the history of
metaphysics what's been going on is
people look to things as being the
standard type of being so a person
is a thing with maybe something else
added and God is you know a thing and a
person too maybe something else he added
as well states of affairs or a bunch of
things put together the world is the
totality of things this is the way that
people have often looked at at matters
trying to avoid the word thing I don't
want to be confusing between my
reference the thing and then Heidegger's
reference the things I'm saying matter
so he talked about these traditional
interpretations of beings he says the
interpretations of the thickness of the
thing which predominate in the course of
Western thought long ago became
self-evident and now are in everyday use
may be reduced to three and that's what
these three are I'm going to skip ahead
a little bit and we're going to explore
you to these in turn the third one's
going to be the most important for us
but we need to look at all of them he
calls these three modes of defining
thing this is a little bit later in the
essay and they conceive of the thing as
a subject and its properties or as a
what he calls a bearer of traits what is
perceptible to the senses or he calls
that a little bit later the unity of the
manifold of sensations or as form matter
and this this term he sticks with over
and over and over again and he says they
have further strengthened their innate
tendency to expand as so as to apply in
the same way to thing to equipment and
to work so before we look at each one of
these inherent and what Heidegger has to
say about them let's talk about the
general complaint the general critique
here the idea is that each one of these
is an interpretation of being but it's
really an interpretation of the thing a
certain type of being that says when we
understand this type of being we
understand beings as such because
they're all basically like this just
with variations these are the three
interpretations that have appeared over
and over and over again throughout the
hits
three of Western metaphysics and when we
say the history of Western metaphysics
we don't mean just metaphysics as a
field we also mean the history of
philosophy in general because whether
you understand this this way or not
epistemology is also metaphysics
epistemology is the metaphysics of
knowledge it's trying to provide an
explanation of what it is to know what
is truth ethics political philosophy is
in a certain way metaphysics theology is
in a certain way metaphysics at least is
the way that Heidegger is understanding
these things understanding these matters
so the first way that he talks about is
subject and predicate and he says this
block of granite is a mere thing it's
hard heavy extended bulky shapeless
rough colored partly Dahl pearly shiny
nice phenomenological description there
we can take note of all these features
in the stone
so we have the stone as a thing and then
it has all these properties the traits
signify something proper to the stone
itself that's what we mean by properties
something proper something that
belonging to it the thing has them what
is the thing that the thing is what
underlies all these properties that we
then perceive can talk about and can
imagine can think about can recognize
that stone just like I have certain
properties I'm not made of stone I made
a flesh mostly walk you know when you
get down to it I'm a certain height
certain age some of these properties
will change over time right some of them
are what we call accidental properties
some other what we call essential
properties or characteristics now the
Greek word for this was crippled Canada
and that's what we translate a subject
in part because that's what the Latins
the Romans translated who became known
as
when they transfer Greek philosophy into
to Latin after the Eclipse of the Greek
world essentially sister wasn't self was
a great part of that process this is
just a side note he actually talks about
you know do we have the capacity here's
where I'm I challenge Heidegger do we
have the capacity to actually render
these these terms into our own language
is our language so impoverished that we
can't make sense out of Greek philosophy
so we can only study in greek cicero
resisted that Heidegger says that people
like Cicero made a big mistake because
they did not go through the primordial
experience of thinking about things
their properties and so when they
transfer the Hoople came it on the Greek
term and concept into the Latin subject
'm that which is literally thrown below
they impoverished the idea they made it
more clear and they also made it less
ontological e rich and dense so as a
Roman thought takes over the Greek words
without a corresponding equally original
experience of what they say without the
Greek word the ruthlessness of Western
thought begins with this translation he
says so according to the current opinion
way in which this come to be understood
this definition of the thing witness of
the thing as the substance with its
accident seems to correspond to our
natural outlook on things we say this is
actually a cup
what is it scuffed as consistent well
this one is actually white it's got a
certain shape to it that I can drink
coffee out of you know it's hard you
know if you're Descartes you could
actually say well it has a certain sound
a tap on it like it has the wax right so
the substance with its accidents and he
says no wonder the current attitude
towards things our way of addressing
ourselves to things has adapted it's
also this common view a simple
propositional statement consists of the
subject and the predicate in which the
things traits are stated of it dr.
Sandler is 40 42
my 43 I'll be 43 soon 43 years old he
currently has a bad knee his hands are
made of flesh tendons bones and other
stuff skin hair blood right so we have
the the subject and we have the
predicate and he says we must ask is
this is the structure of a simple
propositional statement a mirror image
of the structure of the thick or could
it be that the structure of the thing is
lesson vision is a projection of the
framework of the sentence maybe we're
being misled by looking at language
itself as not just a model but sort of
the structure of reality so he says what
happens is human beings transpose their
propositional way of understanding
things into the structure of the thing
itself and this requires explanation he
says first you'd have to actually
explain how these correspond to each
other and that's not often done it's
just assumed so he says actually the
sentence structure does not provide the
standard for the pattern of the thing
structure they actually both derive from
a more original source which we're going
to have to get to any sense why don't we
see this well there's this long
tradition as he calls it of seeing
things this way of engaging in this kind
of interpretation of beings and of
things and so we just become blind to it
we take it a second nature well everyone
knows this to be the case so this must
be the case it becomes part of our our
cultural assumptions so he says in
addition this thing concept the thing is
bear of its characteristics holds not
only the mere thing that's proper sense
but comes to be applied to any being
whatsoever so for example we might ask
of God does is God a subject with
predicates then and you know the
traditional way of dealing with this has
been to say no see God is actually every
single one of his attributes that's how
he's the
which he's different than other other
beings but you notice that even somebody
like Thomas Aquinas was very very you
know keen to stress that when he's
examining something like the ontological
proof he will examine it in terms of is
the predicate contained in the subject
which is using this kind of this kind of
language this kind of interpretation and
this gets extended to all sorts of
beings
Heidegger calls this an assault on being
and he says that we're doing violence to
be a by this and he says there can be a
counter-reaction those people of
disavowal thought for that reason so
you're doing you're doing injustice
you're you're rupturing being you're
you're tearing it apart we don't want to
think that way he says that's not the
cure
instead of like stopping thinking try to
make thought more thoughtful let's look
then at the second interpretation what
is perceptible to the senses he says the
thing is the ice the tome that which
literally is perceived that which is
perceptible by sensations in the senses
belonging to Sensibility
so the concept later becomes a
commonplace according to which of things
nothing but the unity of a manifold of
what is given to the senses so here you
might think about you know somebody like
him what you know Hume rejects the
notion of subject and says well you know
what a thing is is really just a bunch
of sensations or perceptions or
imaginations all put together and we
assume that there's some sort of unity
to them but there really isn't it's it's
just sort of nominally there we give it
a name and so we think that because we
give it a name that that's a you know a
thing as such so he says whether this
unity is conceived of the sum or as
totality or its Gestalt it doesn't make
any difference it's just a bunch of
things
bunch of perceptions put together he
says now this interpretation of the
thickness of the thing is as correct as
demonstrable in every case of the
previous one that's a funny thing to say
isn't it
correct and demonstrable because once
you've assumed this framework of
interpretation well of course everything
fits into that this is why it's hard to
you know sometimes bring somebody like
Hume into contact with somebody like say
Aquinas or Aristotle because they're in
certain ways not even you know sharing
the same framework of understanding so
he says this should actually cast doubt
on its truth the fact that it seems so
obvious to us he says if we consider
what we're searching for this thin
concept it leaves us at a loss we never
really first perceive a throng of
sensations
for example tones and noises and the
appearance of things as this thin
concept alleges that's a problem right
there with this conception it's never
truly a booming buzzing confusion as you
know James called it instead we actually
perceive here's a book
I didn't first perceive ah red and black
and white and put together in this way
this this figure in pattern no I
perceive book at the same time that I
perceived all those those sensations he
says in order to hear a bear sound we
have to listen away from things we have
to actually like abstract in a sensual
way meaning to pull everything else away
from it in order to have these these
single sensations and he says the thing
concept just mentioned there's not so
much an assault on the thing as there is
in this first you know subject-predicate
way of looking at it but rather it in
order to an attempt to bring it into the
greatest possible proximity like right
in front of our face we want you know
just the sensations itself and you see a
lot of people seeking out this this sort
of path to two things
now the third way that he talks about
that he's actually gonna spend a lot
more time money says that which gives
things their constancy in Pitt there is
also the same time the source of the
particular mode a sensuous presence is
the matter in things so in this cup the
matter is porcelain I suppose you'd say
in this paper right glue and think and
things like that in this analysis of the
thing is matter who they in Greek form
morphing in Greek is already co+ what is
constant in a thing it's consistency
lies in the fact that it's matter stands
together with a form the thing is formed
matter so there is the material aspect
of the thing and then there is the shape
the form however you want to express it
to look literally the a dose that it has
so for example now this is plastic
philosophers pretend it was wood or
something like that and you know blade
still has some some herbs on it from
when I was slicing them earlier this is
a great example of a performed manner
the steel itself has a particular shape
to it a particular you know angle size
all that this is a typical chef's knife
it has a function why is it formed in
the way that it is so that it can do
certain things why does this cup have
the form that it does so it can hold
them coffee
if the knife was shaped like the cup it
wouldn't be a very good knife at all
would it if the cup was shaped like the
knife it wouldn't be a very good cup all
the liquid would run out so he says this
concept puts us in a position to answer
the question concerning the Thinley
aspect of the work of art the thing we
element is the matter of which it
consists matters the sub
getting filled through the artist
formative action so the painter for
example what is the matter the canvas
the palette the paint itself when the
pink can be broken down you know you can
go further with your analysis the paint
is actually pigment within a vehicle you
know each of those has its own
characteristics right the thing the
element is is the matter in which it
consists but we could have advanced this
obvious and one long definition at the
very outset why did we make a detour
Heidegger says through other applicable
thin concepts because we also mistrust
this concept of the thing which
represents it as format it's an
interpretation as well is not precisely
this pair of concepts usually employed
in the domain in which we're supposed to
be moving he says yes as a matter of
fact traditional aesthetics is often
taken for matter as it's very paradigm
for understanding the work of art as
something different than a mere thing
you know natural thing as something
different than an organic natural thing
is something different than a mere tool
or something like that this allows us to
think about the intentionality of the
maker the final purpose of it this is
why Aristotle to form matter as being
the paradigm for his metaphysics so he
says the distinction of matter and form
is a conceptual schema which is used in
the greatest variety of ways all
different types of ways quite generally
for all art theory and aesthetics but
here's the problem
it remains an interpretation so now
we're going to move to another concept
in order to make sense out of this we're
going to leave these two behind and
we're going to focus on this form to
matter thing because one of the things
that we want to think about again to use
this knife as an example it has a form a
shape it has matter that it's made of
what determines that is however its
use and it's use is not for chopping its
uses for slicing for for a set of
projects that we have Heidegger would
say so you think about this you know the
book I could use this book as a pillow
but that's not the proper use of the
book the form of matter allows that to
happen but actually it's a lot more
useful if I open it up and read it so
now we want to look at usefulness and
it's connection with formed matter so
the interpretation that Heidegger is
particularly interested in looking at
now is this what about formed matter and
why is he so interested in that well
that one has not not only as we just put
it out been the one that's been
prevalent in theories of art and
aesthetics and understandings of what's
going on in the work of art it also has
a sort of history to it that we want to
look at so he's talked about these three
different modes of interpretation of
things and thereby equipment and of work
and he says that each one of them has
become not only to to a way of thinking
about the thing that also equipment and
work and beings in general so he says
that this long familiar mode of thought
preconceive Zahl immediate experience of
beings that is it filters the way in
which we actually take in what it is
that that confronts us in our lived
experience so he says it shackles
reflection on the being capital B of any
given being thus it comes about that
prevailing thing concepts obstruct the
way towards the thing lead character of
the thing as well as towards the equip
mental character of equipment and all
the more towards the worklet character
of work that's a very important passage
it sounds a little bit trivial like
using on the thing way character of the
thing equip mental value what he's
saying is that this interpretation of
the thing what it is that we're trying
to understand is form matter actually
gets in the way of understanding
what it is for something to be equipment
that category of BA what it is that
something get what it is for something
to be thing Li in the sense of being
made of stone being made of canvas of
blotches of color on it or what is very
thing to actually be a work and how
these are distinct from each other so
what we want to do is try to undermine
this this prejudice this prejudgment
about the nature of beings so he says
that is why it's necessary to know about
these thing concepts in order to take
heed of their Providence and their
boundless presumption but also their
semblance of self evidence it becomes
all the more necessary when we risk the
attempt to bring to view and express in
words the thing Li character the thing
the equip mental character of equipment
and the work lead character the work to
this end however only one element is
needful to keep at a distance all the
preconceptions of the above modes of
thought to leave the thing to rest in
its own self for instance in its thing
being one seems easier than to let a
thing be just the being that it is or he
says does this actually turn out to be
the most difficult of testing actually
letting beings be and he says this is
not just indifference to them this is
the opposite of indifference and this is
where you know reading being a time
would be particularly useful because
that is the dimension of care so getting
back to this now this this idea of form
and matter e says what we're interested
in here is equipment because equipment
tools things that we produce that we
then use for other purposes they are the
real paradigm of formed matter this is
what Aristotle had in mind when he was
thinking in his metaphysics of the four
causes in a particular the formal cause
and the material cause remember if maybe
not remember but maybe I'm informing you
the formal cause is what gives the
intelligibility of the thing as the kind
of thing that is
the essence has to do with the formal
clause the form is impressed upon what
it is that the thing is made of the
matter the hula in Greek the matter also
tells us about what kind of thing it is
so you know a cup is not the same exact
kind of thing even if it is the exact
same shape and purpose function all that
sort of stuff if it's made of plastic as
opposed to me being made of wood or
being made of stone Aristotle also
recognized what we call an efficient
cause that which causes the thing to be
in this case that which imposes the form
upon the matter like an artisan and also
what we call the final cause the purpose
the function the good that it was to to
try to attain and Aristotle like a lot
of people used what Heidegger is calling
equipment as his models so you know if
we make a knife for example we're
imposing a certain form upon say iron or
steel or bronze a person is doing it and
it's for a particular reason this is
what he calls the equip mentality
quality of equipment how shall we
discover what a piece of equipment truly
is so now Heidegger uses a pair of
peasant shoes what are shoes for well
you know you can think about it they
cover the feet they keep the feet from
being injured they allow you to get
purchase they extend your capacity to be
involved with the larger world that's
why we wear shoes you know they could
also convey certain things about your
individuality as a consumer which you
know that's kind of an oxymoron but
peasant shoes are not really doing that
peasant shoes are very utilitarian
therefore getting you from point A to
point B leather personnel carriers as we
used to call them in the army and
they're supposed to protect your feet
them perhaps allow you to exert yourself
more or
strongly so he says if we want to
understand what equipment actually is
what makes it equipment we can't just
look at it in a museum over here or in
our imagination over there or on a
website we need to actually think about
it in terms of the experience of the
person using the equipment like you says
the peasant woman wears her shoes in the
field only here are they are they what
they are they are the more genuinely so
the less the peasant woman thinks about
the shoes while she's at work that's
something about the nature of equipment
the less that we actually have to be
concerned with it and here in terms of
equipment we might actually you know in
our world say technology as well the
less that we have to to think about it
the better it is as equipment for
allowing us to extend our range of what
we want to do so it's he says in the
process of use of equipment that we must
actually encounter the character of
equipment so he brings up van Gogh's
famous paintings of peasant shoes and he
says as long as we only imagine a pair
of shoes in general or simply look at
the empty unused shoes they merely stand
there
we will never discover what the
equipment on being of the equipment in
truth is why not well because it's
something detached abstract unconnected
for us now notice what Heidegger does in
the next passage he says there's a
beautiful poetic description from the
dark opening of the worn inside of the
shoes the toilsome tread of the worker
stares forth in the stiffly rugged
heaviness of the shoes there's the
accumulated tenacity of her slow trudge
through the far spreading and ever
uniform furrows of the field swept by a
raw wind on the leather lie the dampness
and richness of the soil under the soles
stretches the loneliness of the field
path as evening falls in the shoes
vibrates the silent call of the earth
it's quiet gift of the ripening grain
and its unexplained self refusal in the
FAL
desolation of the wintry field this
equipment is pervaded by uncomplaining
worry as to the certainty of bread the
wordless joy of having once more
withstood want the trembling before
impending childbirth in the Shivering at
the surrounding Menace of death now
Heidegger is a person who grew up in
rural Germany so that helps him out
quite a bit in order to be able to think
about this to relate to that in order to
understand a piece of equipment and what
it's doing we have to we have to allow
ourselves to hear the voice of the thing
and the voice of the people who use the
thing where else we're missing out on
something you know you can think about a
wood-burning stove for example I'm
willing to bet that many people have
never actually experienced what it's
like to be in a you know like the cars
diagnose stove heated room are they
missing out on something is this
something that we should you know try to
impose after the rustic experience
that's kind of missing the point to
really understand the experience you
actually have to at least have some
imaginative connection to that
experience and that is often what poetry
allows us to do when it's good poetry a
good artwork in general so now he goes
on and he says this equipment belongs to
the earth and it is protected in the
world of the peasant women I want to put
these two terms down not because we're
going to explore them here but because
they are going to turn out to be
important a little bit later up
equipment is tied to earth and world use
these important categories so he says
perhaps it is only the picture that we
noticed this about the shoes the peasant
woman on the other hand simply wears
them when she takes off her shoes late
in the evening and deep and healthy
fatigue and reaches out for them in the
still dawn she knows all of this without
noticing reflecting so what is the
equipment the equipment Allah being of
the equipment it consists in what we
call usefulness he says this usefulness
itself rests in the abundance of an
essential being of the equipment that we
call reliability we are able to rely
upon the equipment actually doing what
it is that we wanted to do now you
notice that the foreman matter already
involves this other dimension this
purposiveness this for what and it's not
only about being useful in the abstract
but being useful for real tasks and not
useful every once in a while but being
able to rely upon that thing so he says
the equip mental being of equipment
reliability keeps gathered within itself
all things according to their manner and
extent beautiful passage right there and
he talks about you know worn-out
equipment we're not equipment has lost
its reliability and its usefulness is
now just something blank Izzi says it
awakens the impression that the origin
of equipment lies in a mirror
fabricating that impresses a form upon
matter nevertheless and it's genuinely
equip mental being equipment stems from
a more distant source matter and form
and their distinction have a deeper
origin so what is going on here by
analyzing this notion of matter and form
and placing it within this larger
context
this totality we've learned what it
means for this to be what it is and for
things to actually be equipment so he
says the repose of equipment resting
within itself consistent its reliability
only on this reliability to do we
certain what equipment in truth is so if
we want to know what equipment is we
have to look at specific pieces of
equipment and think about what it is for
them to be reliable how did we find this
out he says not by a description and
explanation of the pair of shoes
actually present but by actually looking
at Van Gogh's artwork about them so the
painting he says spoke in the nearness
of the work we are suddenly somewhere
else than we usually tend to be the
artwork lets us know what shoes are in
truth the work tells us about what the
equipment actually is and he says what
happens here what does that work in the
work van gock painting is the disclosure
of what the equipment the pair of
peasant shoes is in truth now he's
bringing in another important concept
truth this being emerges into the
unconcealed meant of its being the
greeks called the unconcealed 'men of
beings all Athiya literally unconcealed
or unbalanced
unhiding lamp awning can mean all those
different things and so now Heidegger is
going to start to talk about the notion
of truth at this point I don't want to
break and it's a little bit before the
actual break that he has in his text
with the section headings but I want to
stop here and think about what we've
actually what we've actually done we
started that with thinking about the
artist and the work of art and the
larger conception of art and we're
trying to find the origin and the
essence of it we looked at three
prevalent preconceptions about things
and there
thing ly status and what it means to be
a thing we we saw that each one of them
in its weight keeps us from from making
further progress on the path that we
want towards the origin of the work of
art and then we looked at this one in
particular the thing is formed matter
and we saw that we also have to look at
the totality of what's going on and
where I want to leave off is Heidegger
is going to caution us about taking
equipment itself as being as such he
doesn't want us to interpret everything
in terms of equipment he warns us for
example about a way of seeing everything
as equipment which actually turns out to
be here we go
the inclination to treat the matter form
structure as the constitution of every
being receives an additional impulse
from the fact that on the basis of
religious faith name with a biblical
faith where God is the creator the great
artisan the totality of all beings is
represented in advance of something
created which here means made the
philosophy of this faith can of course
assure us that God's creative work is to
be thought it was different than the
craftsmen's work so this is not the
model but very often what ended up
happening with Christian metaphysics was
a fall back into this model and treating
created things as merely informed manner
with God is the ultimate creator and
then his purposes is the purpose behind
them like he says to this idea of
creation grounded at faith can lose its
power for knowledge of being as a whole
but the theological interpretation once
it's in place in the last can if you
take God out of the picture can become
what happens in modern philosophy
running all the way from Descartes
through to somebody like comment and he
brings up count here talking about the
conscient transcendental and all of
these presuppose of certain metaphysics
in which being
comes to be understood in terms of
equipment now the problem with that is
that we also want to understand these
other categories as well so that's we're
going to leave off and we will approach
those in the next talk through the
conception of truth